is max today we are comparing the brand
new
samsung galaxy buds plus against
apple's airpods pro and we're going to
take a look at everything
from active noise cancellation ambient
and transparency modes
sound quality with a variety of genres
latency when you're playing games
and much more and by the end of this
video you will know
which one of these you should buy
regardless if you own a samsung
or an iphone as far as price the airpods
pro are
50 more expensive 250 compared to 200
but that's the msrp price you guys
probably know you can get some sweet
deals right now you might even be able
to pick up
the airpods pro for less than the new
galaxy buds pro so we're gonna have
some links to the best deals down in the
video description let's quickly touch on
the cases and the airpods pro case is
nicer the quality feels a lot better it
is thinner
it is smaller overall and it is less
noticeable in your pocket samsung
switched from using the previous galaxy
but style case
to the galaxy buds live case and so it
isn't as
long but it is more squarish and you do
notice it a little bit more in your
pocket now they also made some
improvements
the magnet is much stronger now so it
won't accidentally open
and the magnets inside that hold the
buds are also a much stronger so they
won't fall out
as far as charging and battery life the
air pods use a lightning port compared
to usb type
c and both of these do have wireless
charging both of these have fast charge
capability and as far as battery life
they are fairly close
but rated battery life samsung is a
little bit ahead both on the buds
themselves
and with the total capacity in the case
comparing the buds themselves
there is a huge difference in design air
pods
like usual have this stem the pros have
a shorter stem
and the actual part that goes into your
ear is much smaller the galaxy butts pro
all of that got much larger than before
it it sticks out slightly more it's a
lot more bulbous
so in general it's quite a bit larger
than the airpods
pro as far as comfort the airpods pro
are more comfortable at least
in first impressions and in my use you
actually
don't really notice a silicone tip being
inside of your ear
and that's because of the design which
i'll show you but also because of the
air vent
that equalizes the pressure it makes
them very
comfortable now the galaxy buds pro i
haven't used them for that much
yet but in my ear i feel the shape all
around
my ear it's much more present and then
also it is
sealed without an air vent so you have a
little bit more pressure build up
with that said the galaxy buds pro are
much more comfortable than
before that's because samsung redesigned
the
silicone tips they're much thicker and
then the actual stem is much shorter
here so the stem doesn't really go into
your ear
just like the air pods pro where it's
just that silk on tip so good job
samsung
as far as controls the galaxy buds just
use this touch surface you can tap it
you can multi-tap it to do
different functions and it actually
works surprisingly well i feel like
samsung
upped the sensitivity maybe or just the
responsiveness it works great
with that said the airpods pro they take
a different method
where you have a little stem and you
actually just press down and you get a
little notification
a little click when it activates and
that allows you to do the same thing
press it multiple times or hold it down
if you want to switch between
your active noise cancellation and
transparency modes and now let's go
ahead and compare
the sound quality i'm very excited to
hear these out i've used the airpods
pros
ever since they came out and these
galaxy bud pros not only do they have
those
dual drivers you have a separate tweeter
and a woofer samsung has improved the
sound as well
so let's go ahead and take a listen i'm
going to start out with this first track
that we use
all the time and let's see what we hear
sounds good
[Music]
vocals are clear
[Music]
not bad on the mids
good bass good strong clean bass
[Music]
these still they sound very nice i have
no complaints at all
let's go grab these put them out and
let's take a listen
to the galaxy buds pro now with these
you do have different eq settings and i
might tweak it we'll go ahead and see
uh but let's just hear how they sound
out of the box
brighter highs definitely
[Music]
the mids are a little bit more rich
[Music]
wow bass sounds very similar
maybe a little bit stronger but like the
sound signature is
very similar
okay that sounds good definitely better
the sound is definitely better not by
much but this song is
an easier song to play so let's go ahead
and switch over to our modern classical
song here so there's some nice bass and
piano notes
uh this is a great track to listen to
um this time i'm gonna not talk while i
listen
you guys can just watch me we'll flip
back and forth between
both and then i'll give you guys my
[Music]
opinion
[Music]
all right very very interesting so
first off let's talk about the good the
base in here is
really rich you definitely can tell the
difference in
this track now on the negative side
uh first off it's quite a bit quieter i
mean i like music loud
but there definitely is a volume
difference between these two earbuds the
airpods max get
louder in here it was mainly kind of
dominated by
the highs and then also the lows the
mids were kind of
lacking now the other positive is
towards the end of that track there's a
really tough spot where there's a lot of
different sounds being mixed together
the airpod pros sound like it's kind of
just blended together you don't have as
much separation
whereas the dual drivers here do make it
sound
more crisp and clean i guess if i could
say that
but overall i definitely prefer the air
pods pro with this track now give me
just a second
i'm gonna go into the galaxy wearables
app here
and i'm gonna change the equalizer from
the default normal
let's switch to dynamic i really like
that setting with the previous ones
and let me take a quick listen i'll get
back to you all right that
is really weird so when we go from the
normal setting to dynamic
the only thing that really changes is
the bass goes down a little bit and the
high frequencies are toned down a little
bit
and it sounds a little bit more balanced
but at the same time it is quieter
which with the previous galaxy buds when
you go to dynamic it made it sound
better and more rich now the other thing
i didn't mention is
that uh the sound stage it is a
noticeable
difference it's not huge between the
galaxy buds pro and the airpods pro but
the airpods pro they do have a little
bit of a sound stage just slightly wider
than my head so the sound isn't just
in my ear drums the galaxy brush pro are
a little bit narrower that's what i was
showing with my hands
and maybe that's because of the actual
little active
vent in here that makes him uh seem more
like
open back headphones but if you want
good sound stage the galaxy butts
live are really great in this area
and now let's push his earbuds to their
limits with a rock song
and this is by far the most difficult
test and i think this is where
the galaxy buds pro could excel with
those
dual drivers and let's go ahead and
take a it listen is
[Music]
is
[Music]
all right guys wow first off i went to
the title app
and there's a setting called loudness
normalization that was turned on by
default
um and for the other songs i didn't
really do much for the rock song it
turned that sucker
down so i re-listened to it after that
wow if you're listening to rock music
by the galaxy buds pro man these sounded
great you have this little synth track
in the background you hear it at the
start
and then when there's all the different
layers of music
the drums the bass guitar it just kind
of like
gets hidden you almost don't hear it
with the airpods
pro and then in the mids the
some part of that drum it's all kind of
more blended it doesn't sound
bad but doesn't sound great you could
still enjoy rocky music but man
these sounded fantastic now as far as
sound leakage vadim
what did you hear i'd say that both of
them i could hear the music but
with the airpods pro it was definitely
much louder sound leakage
yeah and as far as volume once we shut
that setting off
and having good quality from tidal they
were very similar in
volume and i probably wouldn't be
listening to it that loud for too long
even though i do like loud music so i
feel like
maybe we have more sound leakage with
the airpods pro because of that
vent on the back that equalizes the
pressure and that's probably also why
it has better sound stage because it's
more like a open
back or not a sealed design so if you
don't want people to hear your music
the galaxy buzz pro are a little bit
better in that aspect
and now let's test out the movie
watching experience i have
end game opened up right here at a great
scene
the airpods pro supports spatial audio
with surround sound
in the galaxy buds pro they also support
dolby atmos which i have enabled
ian 360 sound which is more for music
but let's go ahead and pop these in of
course i can't play this
the audio back for you guys but i'm
going to take a listen and compare them
i guess what i realize most is i want to
watch that movie again
but there are definitely some
differences now as far as
surround sound it's hard to tell the
difference
but it does sound it sounds pretty good
um
the airpods max they have a feature of
spatial audio when you turn your head it
tracks where the screen is so it's
directional
the galaxy buds don't have that but the
biggest difference that i noticed
is how rich and deep the base is
with the galaxy buds pro since it has a
dedicated driver
it's able to just get a lot more low end
grunt and get a little bit deeper and
richer in four movies it's definitely
better with the galaxy buds pro and now
let's compare probably the biggest new
addition to samsung's
galaxy buds and that's active noise
cancellation i'm gonna go ahead and
start out with the airpods pro
you definitely do get some blockage so
we have a vent in that corner
and it does block out even if in the off
mode
maybe half of the noise or so 50 i think
that sounds about right
let's go ahead and pop in the galaxy
buds pro
and these do block out more sound not
only in that vent but in my voice it
blocks out a lot of the highs
now let's go ahead and put these in the
active noise cancellation mode
and it doesn't do that much at least to
the sound that we have
here my voice is lower that's a little
bit less noticeable but
not as good as i expected and that is in
the high mode let's put in the
airpods pro all right yeah so these it's
interesting my voice
retains some of the high frequencies
more so maybe because that
that little vent the air vent ac vent
there
that is almost completely gone i can
barely hear it so these probably get rid
of about
90 percent of the sound or so whereas i
would say probably the galaxy butts pro
there may be more like 60 to 70 percent
as far as low kind of rumbling sounds
and now let's see how well they do with
higher frequency
mixed sounds i have a video here with
people
talking and i'm gonna set it right in
front of me maybe about a foot and a
half two feet away
and we'll start out with the galaxy buds
pro all right i still hear that
quite a bit let me go to the off mode
[Applause]
it's pretty much not getting rid of the
high frequency sounds i can hear the low
frequency go away
all right interesting and for the
airpods pro let's go ahead and put into
noise cancellation mode
wow very very similar result the high
frequencies
it really struggles with getting rid of
those it did get
more rid of a lot more low frequencies
but i guess with earbuds let me turn off
that annoying sound
with these earbuds there's not that much
they can do compared to
over ear headphones like the the sony's
or the airpods
max but overall the active noise
cancellation is superior
on the airpods pro and now let's compare
the ambient
and transparency modes with both of
these
samsung made some really good
improvements but let's see how they
compare
right now i'm using the default medium
setting and
the vent sounds very natural the air
coming through
just a little rumble my voice is a
little bit
digitized a little bit kind of tinny but
overall it doesn't sound too bad would
you go ahead and talk
hey man how do i sound you sound better
than me maybe my voice is just too close
you sound very natural
we can also go into high setting that
sounds
louder especially my voice and extra
high okay that sounds
really weird really terrible but if you
need to hear somebody far away
it's going to work but the medium
default setting way
wow way now my voice sounds normal just
because i heard how bad it sounded in
the high setting
let's go ahead and put in my ear pods
we'll switch it to transparency mode
and there you go that sounds great the
vent
sound is very similar to the galaxy buds
pro
but my voice sounds pretty much the same
very close to real life let me go ahead
and say something hey man how do i sound
completely natural everything's not as
loud so everything even the media mode i
guess gets louder on the galaxy
but pro but i'd say apple definitely has
the better ambient mode
as well now samsung does have a special
feature which i think is super cool
and it's called voice detect when you
have them in
you're an active noise cancellation and
then as soon as you start talking about
two seconds later
it automatically switches to your
ambient mode so you walk up to somebody
and start talking to them so you have to
manually do it and then when you stop
about 10 seconds later
it will go back into active noise
cancellation and with that
let's compare the microphone quality we
know the airpod pros
smoke the previous galaxy buds and buds
plus but samsung said they've made some
really good improvements let's go and
pop these in and let's take a listen
this is a microphone quality that you
can expect with samsung's new
galaxy buds pro in an environment that
does
have some extra noise and this is the
microphone quality with apple's air pods
pro
in an environment that does have some
fairly good room noise
all right guys go ahead let me know down
in the comment section below
which one of these two sound better in
terms of microphones i want to hear you
guys opinions
and now let's compare how they do for
gaming the galaxy buds pro
they do have a gaming mode so i'm going
to go ahead and enable that
that's going to minimize the delay and
then i'm going to go ahead and open up
call of duty mobile and we'll run a few
tests
and the delay surprisingly isn't that
bad i think they might have improved it
there's a delay maybe 200 milliseconds
or maybe
300 and then for the airpods pro
definitely less delay maybe half the
delay or so so i might be about right so
i know these are about 150 milliseconds
and those sounded like maybe 300 now
what i was really curious about is how
do the airpods pro work
with the samsung or another android
phone as far as
latency and switching back and forth i
mean the latency is pretty much the same
as the galaxy
buds pro of course we don't have that
gaming toggle and i gotta say that's
pretty interesting because in the past
even if you had a samsung phone
you were better off buying airpods if
you were a gamer
because you'd have roughly 300
milliseconds of latency compared to five
to 700
with the older different versions of
galaxy but if you are an
android phone user you're not going to
get any downside
if you decide to go with airpods pro
over
other earbuds and now for our final
verdict
which one of these are better and which
one should you buy
first off i think price really matters
as i mentioned at the start we have
links to the best deals in the video
description
and at the time of this video you can
buy both of these
for a very similar price but that is
gonna change in the future
typically samsung earbuds they do go
down in price there's some great sales
the other difference that's kind of
obvious is if you have an android phone
or especially a samsung you have those
extra features
like that 360 and atmos sound and then
you also have the ability for it to read
out your messages which is nice
same thing with the iphone you have the
spatial audio and you have
siri support and siri messages if you
care about
sound quality ultimately you want the
best sound the galaxy buzz pro
definitely sound better with those dual
drivers and other updates especially for
rock music but overall
they sound fantastic and you can also eq
them whereas the airpods pro
they sound good but they do not sound as
good especially
in rock music where you have a lot of
different things going on
now with that said if you're somebody
that ultimately cares about active noise
cancellation and with that ambient mode
and then possibly microphones you guys
are gonna have to tell us
um which one sounds better in mics i
think the airpods pros
are a great buy and then also if you
care about gaming
and even if you're somebody that has an
android phone or a samsung
but you want to get that great active
noise cancellation i would suggest
getting a pair of air pods
they keep the resale value really well
um the active noise cancellation works
just as good with the samsung phone
and they're great headphones overall
with really good comfort so there you
guys go go ahead let me know in the
comments if there was
anything that surprised you about either
one of these and how they compare
and you guys can click that circle above
to subscribe and help us reach our goal
of 600k subs
before our two year mark in march click
one of those great videos over there to
check those out this one max and i'll
see you in the next video